all right
[Music]
welcome back to the official winning
time podcast from HBO I'm Rodney Barnes
executive producer on the show magic and
the Lakers are back to defend their
title what a time to be alive over the
next seven weeks I'll be joined by
actors directors and key collaborators
to break down each episode of season two
it's not about basketball it's about
winning we'll also unpack the real
events that make it into the show with
sports writer Jeff Perlman his book
about the showtime Lakers of the 1980s
inspired winning time so after the
Lakers win this game that they shouldn't
have won on a court they shouldn't have
won on the fans went crazy and all these
things actually happened listen to HBO's
official winning time podcast on Sunday
August 6th right after the premiere of
season two on Max new podcast episodes
come out every Sunday night immediately
following new episodes of the series
listen on Max or wherever you get your
podcast